in this episode of cloud performance
atlas we help some happy honey makers
fix their regional performance want to
see what all the buzz is about stay
tuned to find out the bee party is a
conservation focused organization which
provides data scientists researchers
farmers and agricultural companies with
the data they need to help preserve the
mighty honeybee since their efforts had
now achieved critical mass their
technology teams started getting
complaints from their global regions the
data access was slower than desired
now regional performance is a common
problem because you know physics but if
the network has been set up properly
this shouldn't be an issue anyhow when
we talk about latency one of the most
important things we must remember is
that it's a function of physics the
speed of light traveling through a
fiber-optic cable takes roughly about
ten milliseconds to travel about a
thousand kilometres so the further away
you are from your destination the higher
your latency this is why Google cloud
platform places new data centers in
various regions around the world the
goal is to find the sweet spot between
distance latency and disaster tolerance
to get a sense of this behavior I set up
an instance in each GCP region and
pinged them from my desktop machine here
in Austin Texas
about a hundred times as expected the
farther away the instance is the worse
the latency to it but I'm just one data
point probably more important is to
understand the performance between each
region which is what's straightforward
to test
we already had the instances set up in
each region so we just had to measure
the throughput from one location to each
other location from this graph we can
clearly see that the Europe West to Asia
East and the US West to Asia East are
some of the lowest throughput
connections while any of the u.s. to us
connections have some of the highest
throughput now that we have an
understanding of baseline performance
let's try to figure out how the B party
is set up and as always I start with
logging data looking at the user agents
fields of our logs we can see that most
of their requests are coming from
desktop connections this is good since
it means we're not getting skewed
results due to 2g or 3G connection
speeds no worries there when we drill in
some we can see the slower traces we can
start to see a consistent pattern most
of the highest density and latency
traces are coming from areas in Japan
this threw up a big red flag for me
since I
knew that the B party was a non-profit
company stationed out of Europe a quick
phone call with their CTO confirmed this
the B party is based out of Germany and
they deploy all their GCE instances in
the European region well of course
there's our problem the majority of
their clients are coming from Japan
while the instances are only deployed in
Europe from our previous graph we saw
that this was already one of the lowest
performing connections the solution for
the B party was quite clear they need to
deploy instances of their VMs in regions
closer to their primary user base which
requires us to change two things firstly
is creating a new instance group for the
Asia East region so the researchers in
Japan can be connecting to the closest
instance as possible secondly is putting
together a global HTTP load balancer
whose job is to route request to the
nearest healthy instances this way
clients in Japan get their packets
routed to the Asia East cluster rather
than having to go all the way to Europe
for it oh by the way
did you know that Japan has one of the
most awesome type of honeybee on the
planet the Japanese honeybee has a
unique defense for fighting predatory
wasps they swarm it hug it and start
vibrating fast enough to raise the
internal heat of their bee ball to 117
degrees Fahrenheit killing the Hornet
but leaving the bees unharmed which you
got to admit it's pretty cool anyhow if
you'd like to improve the performance of
your cloud applications don't forget to
check out the rest of our cloud
performance Atlas content and when it
comes to the environment remember every
honeybee cows
[Music]